I think that the importance about
leadership in general is to one thing is
of course to understand what you deliver
to customers
and get the right people in right people
is people who are able to to uh to
develop this uh this product so be
Innovative that's for me is very
important welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
another amazing episode with Wilco
visher the CEO at Value blue a company
behind the SAS platform Blue Dolphin an
Enterprise architecture tool for agile
business transformation prior to
starting the company in 2011 Wilco spent
time as a senior executive across both
self-started organizations and private
corporations with thousands of employees
a strong believer in the promises of
digital transformation Wilco is excited
about the Innovation Blue Dolphin is
enabling for organizations across the
globe
welcome Fisher welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from New York how
are you
very good it's in a bright and fantastic
day today
definitely looks that way uh very
jealous of you and thank you again for
being here uh Walter the CEO of valiant
blue and Company that's behind the SAS
products Blue Dolphin looking at agile
business transformation generally
something that's not very intuitive and
I'm really curious to hear about how SAS
makes it better and how you're doing it
at scale through value blue as well as
sort of where this whole company came
from for you and what this represents in
your own journey and you as an
entrepreneur in leadership style so a
lot a lot for us to uncover in 20 short
but meaningful minutes and starting the
journey all the way back from from the
Netherlands so welcome tell me a little
bit about your own Journey leading up to
a value bloom
well I started this company in 2011.
before that I was a manager that's a
large company uh it's called eighth of
us in in Europe they have around 120 000
employees and I was responsible for
parts with around 12 1300 employees wow
and before that I had my old company
also so I have started a few companies I
saw that through an Austrian company in
2005 this is a long time ago
and I must say after that I sold it I
had to work there for two more years and
and it was really going fantastic so
every month the Figures were better than
expected and then we had to go to Vienna
to uh to report and these were really
fun trips because and the results were
better so everybody was happy and Vienna
is a fantastic City to be once a month
so but after that I went to working for
eight office as a big company
there I saw the power of Enterprise
architecture I didn't know that very
well and business Process Management and
then I thought after three years
I thought I'm going to start my company
on that area and Enterprise architecture
is about understanding how your business
is structured your business processes
how the people work together and
interact with the customers and how you
can improve that with it and this data
and I was sure then in 2011 that
understanding the business and
everything all ID that the company is
would be more important 10 years later
than it was at that moment and now 10
years later it's really true you see
that it's now much more like digital
transformation is all over the place
everybody's talking about it that was
not the case to 10 years ago
uh but still I believe that it changes
further in 2030 it will be even more
important than you will have artificial
intelligence and all kinds of process
automation that you already have of
course everybody is used to buy stuff
online and only the the the the
um
the customer Journeys they call it so if
you buy something from Amazon you choose
something and then you select and you
pay and they process and then you get
the product at all that is a customer
journey and what we are now used to that
these customer Journeys are completely
automated and really working without any
problems but they years ago it was
hardly possible to uh to order anything
uh online so you see how fast it goes
and I think that that Enterprise
architecture digital transformation
business Process Management these are
the central elements in in these
developments in these trends
and so
yeah how do you actually do that through
a SAS product how does that even work
yeah what we the focus we have is on
very large organizations so we we focus
on companies like uh word Fern Food
cooperation with 70 000 employees or
Hogue medical group of Rite Aids is a
pharmaceutical company these kinds of
companies
and those only in the United States but
also in uh in Europe we have a lot of
these big companies and what you see is
they have a lot of information in
different systems and we upload this
information in our system
and our system you can see there's a
kind of collaboration platform for
everyone in an organization
who is involved in in digital
transformation or in Innovation you can
say and these are a lot of people these
are not only Enterprise Architects or
other Architects but also application
owners or business managers or c-level
who want to understand how are my
corporate objectives being a realized
through all kinds of initiatives and
projects well done you have the current
situation
and all kinds of projects and
initiatives to change things to innovate
and can be hundreds of initiatives
simultaneously in a large organization
and what our tool does is visualizing
and what's the current situation where
the the desired situation per project or
initiative but also what are all the
different projection initiation and how
are they interested in each other what
are relations independencies you can
show that the visualize that in our
system and so at the Strategic level the
sea level can see what's happening and
how are we proceeding a related
realizing our corporate objectives on
technical level you can do a portfolio
management so make the environment the
total environment simpler and see how
things are going
an operational every individual project
people in such projects know what is the
current situation what do we need to do
and how do we need to do it like a
design of a designful building and and
uh for uh erecting and building for
example this Supermarket sorry no
worries
so that's uh actually what we what we do
so with different Business Leaders and
Executives this and organizations that
are adopting and integrating this system
what what what is sort of their
perspective as they are integrating it
when as you're sort of from the market
perspective how is the market perceiving
you as they're integrating this product
well what we do is that we we position
our product these are products you can
do quite a lot of different use cases
so you can simplify the application
landscape or you can simplify the
business processes or you can define a
customer Journey like I just explained
there are a lot of different things that
you can do with it what we what we
normally
do together with the customer is Define
where is the biggest problem and then
you start with one or two use cases and
make that uh happen and and create value
and from there we helped customers he
call that customer success management so
the customer and and consultancies
assigned to a customer
and uh and he helps the customer to
gradually experience this code so from
from a narrow scope where you will
Define and create value and and results
and you can step by step exponent scope
and and make the product more and more
strategic within an organization but
you're right
it's not possible for organization and
certainly when they don't have the
experience with other tools in one step
to uh to fully implement this along all
levels that's not possible we have to to
do it gradually
so what do you find where do you find to
be the low-hanging fruit for the common
organization what's been sort of a
Common Thread that's been providing some
immediate value in your eyes that's a
good question what you see is that most
companies don't have a good Insight in
their current I.T landscape and how did
it landscape you and talking about
applications and data how that's really
supports the business processes and and
the business and interaction with the
customer that is not uh clearly
documented so the first thing what we do
is and and the reason why it's not clear
is because this information is in all
kind of different systems that are not
connected to each other what we do is we
get this information from all the system
out of it and imports in our system and
then immediately you get a lot of extra
insights just by combining the
information that's now scattered in in
different sources and then we also we
can see what information do we have and
what do we miss and then we can focus on
getting the the important information
that we miss and from there we can see
uh well what are the biggest problems in
your in your uh for example landscape
over your business process processes
where can we reduce the number of
applications and reduce costs or where
can we optimize certain things
so the first step is always getting the
picture rights and from there looking
for the low ending fruits to create
failure and after that is much more
towards planning strategy defining a
strategy and Innovation but it interface
is mostly not the first step the first
step is just getting the picture of the
good situation
interesting it really gives a lot of
value if you don't have it if you didn't
have it before
right no no for sure tell me a little
bit about your own leadership style or
leadership Journey you've had quite a
bit of experience as a leader in
different organizations what what what's
what have you been converging on your
own leadership style
well I think that uh the importance
about leadership in general is to one
thing is of course to understand what
you deliver to customers
uh and get the right people in right
people is people who
um are able to to uh to develop this uh
this product so be Innovative that's for
me a very important
and on different areas in the
organization have the knowledge and have
done it before so we are growing quite
fast because
um we have and we have a venture capital
backed and uh for example this year we
doubled in in the number of employees
wow so what we need is all the different
parts of the organizations people with
um and managed organizations that are
two or three or four times as big as us
so they have done it before and that's
important and there for me very
important is to create a team and to
create a mutual goal and also to trust
people of course I uh they need to
deliver you have to have results so I'm
very resource driven but I'm not
interfere with every detail if you have
the right people they must they must be
able to have the freedom to uh to act
and and to collaborate with the others
and well I think that's that's really
important and another thing with for me
uh important there are two things that
are crucial for me one is that we want
to be a company
for customers that is nice to do
business with and you can
translate it all kind of things it has
to do with how you interact how you do
uh selling and not in an aggressive way
but we want to sell something that the
customer resilient has benefited from
but also the product must create value
because if you don't create value then
the customers don't like doing business
with us and the same is for uh for
employees so we also want to be a
company where people really like to to
work and and that means that uh that's
that's yeah you must have the feeling
that it's nice to have the police that
you work with and that is that there
isn't jealousying uh goal in the
organization itself has said that we do
special we we are now a company
worldwide so not only in the US but also
in Europe and also in Asia we have large
customers with the biggest customers
have more than hundred thousand
employees and we started to small in the
Netherlands so all the the employees
really have the feeling that we are uh
we are writing an incredible journey and
we are realizing things that that nobody
thought would be possible a few years
ago and that's really nice to be part of
so how do you as you're growing uh so
dramatically and you're expanding and
you're growing not just the team but the
product and your customer base how do
you how do you design success for for
Blue Dolphin and and value blue in
general how do you know that you're on
the right track of of creative values is
there a way to actually measure it to be
data driven about it is it more from
feedback from customers and seeing their
use cases what's been sort of your your
North Star on this
we we are very data driven in every
aspect both in the product itself but
also in sales and marketing
but in a very important uh data points
uh reflecting the customer
satisfaction is the true
so our churn has been in the in all the
years before below five percent in turn
means the number of customers that stop
using the product
so and the the efforts in the markets in
our Market is around 15 So Below five
percent is really low and that means
that customers that this that figure in
itself means already that customers are
satisfied apart from that for example we
had our we call it transform 2022 this
year that's our big event for both
customers and uh and potential customers
and what he saw there was that 70 of our
customers joined so they have a really a
high level of commitments and we have a
lot of reference customers who like to
tell potential customers how satisfied
they are and also we have uh per half
year a review and and both a
quantitative and a qualitative uh
interview with every customer to ask
them how they feel about product what is
the the results and the benefit they get
from it and what other wishes they have
and we do that every year for every
customer and there we can see all kinds
of trends so what we see is that the
trend is in a good direction and that's
that's good for now
but it's very important to keep on
measuring that it is quite a lot of work
to do it but I think it's the the of
course we have a vision where we want to
be but the fishing muscle aligned with
what customers who are using the
products how they think and we pay a lot
of attention to that
interesting and so tell me a little bit
about the founding story of this you're
you know you mentioned a little bit
about your previous experiences a little
bit about where this idea came from what
was the start of this journey like for
you as an entrepreneur
yeah I started the company yes Uncle
schulzy company
and uh I called it uh failure blue uh
failure is value and blue stands for
Innovation for me so this is the
background
and uh well we've read the service Sony
area of Enterprise architecture and
business policy management you need
tools to visualize it if you describe
with words an Enterprise architecture or
an I.T landscape nobody will will be
able to read it this is not nice to do
that but when you make picture it's very
easy you see it's right away that's much
more interesting also
and what we saw was that the tools in
the market that were available were so
complex that only the the Enterprise
Architects would work with that who I
visit every day but for us it should be
an and platform the Enterprise architect
is the architect but he's doing nothing
like the architecture of a building he's
not erecting the building itself so you
need all the people who are involved in
Innovation to be able to work with two
like that also and that's what we
decided to make a tool what that was a
true collaboration tool for everyone in
the organization evolved in changing
Innovation
so that was the idea and then we had to
define a name and it should be something
collaborative of course so and it should
also have some relation with cellular
blue so when we were thinking about the
name someone said blue shark and
everywhere said no no that's not a good
name but then there was so so on he said
blue dolphin and everyone says well
that's fantastic because a dolphin is a
sympathetic collaborative intelligent
anymore so and the nice thing is that
wherever we go when we say the name Blue
Dolphin nobody forgets it it's a really
appealing name yeah it's a very good
name
I love it and the reason for creating
for choosing a different name versus the
company name and that that in in it it
increases the complexity but I'm sure
there's an upside as well so what was
the consideration there well I must be
honest and we didn't consider that so
well at that moment we just thought we
need a name for the promise and you're
right it gives some extra complexity so
if you look at the Garden Master
quadrants where we are already for four
years uh mentioned then they call US
Cellular blue and not blue Dolph because
then they call they named the the
company name so we really didn't think
about that
when we thought about the name and
we have been uh thinking about uh using
the the company name instead of the
products but
well Letting Go Blue Dolphin as a name
is is uh still too difficult for us so
yeah we cannot do this yet well I guess
it must mean that it's a good name then
yeah and uh and Wilton I really want to
appreciate and thank you for your time
this is it sounds like a great journey
it sounds like a really great Insight
that can help us serve as a platform
um for leaders around the world so thank
you for for the time and the energy and
the thoughtfulness and I really look
forward to sharing this episode with
friends and family so thank you very
very much and best of luck with value
blue and blue dolphin and with your own
Journey
thank you Michaels thank you very much
for this conversation thank you very
very much
[Music]